hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from the 2018 Batumi
chess olympiad it's a game from round
four and it's played between world chess
championship challenger Fabiana Khurana
and former world champion Vishwanath on
almond well rather Anand is still the
world champion only in rapid chess but
regarding classical chest he is the
formal role champion before we check out
the game and it's a very nice
theoretical struggle now we do have a
couple of nice photos here you have a
wonderful photo of vasily von Schuch the
photo was taken by Goga Sean Daly and
you can check a lot more of her photos
from this event there will be a link in
the description below as usual all of
the links from the Batumi Chess Olympiad
will be down below so do check them out
but yeah feel free to check out this
wonderful photo by Chuck it's it's a
wonderful moment in space and time so by
all means feel free to caption this
photo in the comments below then we have
another nice photo also by Goga there
you have it
before the game Anand is shaking
Carmona's hand and you can see that
Westley sewing the Hikaru Nakamura have
matching tuxedos and it seems that
Corwin and some Shanklin are too cool to
also wear matching tuxedos I don't know
it's not not very team spirit Lee like
but okay yeah you know to each his own I
guess then we have also a very nice
photo it's the first couple of moves
have been played and I really like
islands a little cup there with the logo
of the 2018 but to me chess olympiad
and lastly I thought you'd enjoyed this
one its photo by the official
photographer of the Batumi chess
olympiad David Lada
this is Hikaru Nakamura and Fabiano
Caruana
with the Uganda women's team and if
you've seen the movie the queen of cat
way the woman on the far left is
actually a Fiona MOTC whom the movie was
based upon the delete character so hope
you enjoyed that now let's check out
this very nice game Caruana has the
white pieces and he opens with d4 we
have Knight to f6 C 4 and the e 6 and
here we have G 3 so the cattle and
opening the 5 by Anand Bishop to g2 we
have d captures on c4
Queensway for with check black has the
blog this check Knight to d7 is played
and here we have Queen captures on c4
now Corona recaptures the pawn we have a
six and this is the exact same position
that was on the board during the Tata
Steel 2018 tournament Anand also had the
black pieces and he was playing against
onigiri in this position
Anish went Queen to c2 and the game
continues c5 which is the pretty
standard replied the Queen to c2 and
then I have three and so on and so on
that game was was drawn between onigiri
and Vishwanath an island and it's very
interesting the Queen to c2 is the most
often played move here and it is in fact
the strongest move recommended by the
engine but the move Caruana played was
never played before it's it's also an
engine move but it's the engines the
second recommendation
the move is Bishop to e3 and there is no
this position has never been found
before in tournament play there is no
position like this in the database and
it's a move you can't really play unless
you've really prepared it at home
because there are so many things you
have to consider what if this Knight
comes to g4 and attacks my bishop here
so and I definitely a move prepared at
home but you'll see what I mean by this
a little bit later I don't know it
doesn't really take too much time even
though it's not the mainest of lines he
plays the DC 6 and Anand only took four
minutes for this move so ok Queen to c2
Caruana
quickly replies he spent some three
minutes on Queen c2 and here Anand
castles we have a nice to h3 and now we
see the problem of this position unlike
the position of a shrunken head against
onigiri in the Tata Steel chess
tournament in that game under simply
continue with c5 b 5 he developed the
light-square bishop but here while this
dark square Bishop is an e3 and this
light square bishop is now opened such
ideas are not really possible and
that's the idea behind placing the
knight on h3 instead of an f3 and at
some point this night will come to f4 so
what's the idea if you play something
like Knight to g4 here it seems like a
very nice move kicking away the white
bishop but doesn't really do anything
for example Bishop to g5 attacking the
Queen and now you simply have to move
the knight back and you've just improved
the position of whites dark square
bishop the problem is after this Bishop
to g5 move a very interesting variation
although not really working for black is
Knight d2 f6 and now it seems like this
Knight is trapped what if f3 is played
then black has this very nice move
Knight captures on h2 now of course
you're not gonna capture the night
because then you allow Bishop captures
on g3 here white have white has a bush
up to h4 guarding this opponent now
black is black losing the piece here so
here black can play h6 preparing g5 to
trap the dark square Bishop here and
then white can go Queen to d2 and it's a
very very complicated position that that
really favors white and no doubt that
Caruana
had this all figured out even before the
game started because now g5 is
impossible you will simply capture the
pawn Knight captures captures captures
and after the King moves you have so
many options with white whenever you
prefer you can recapture your piece you
can go rook captures on h2 this is the
best you can see the king is trapped on
the H file when this bishop moves it's
all over black is completely lost here
so after Knight to h3 Anand goes he 5
and it's definitely a nice move a very
principled move kuranes king is still in
the center so we definitely want to open
up the center you you wanted this Bishop
to be able to develop so II five very
nice
we have castles by Caruana now comes h6
taking away the g5 square from kuranes
night and and perhaps the bishop
lee captures on e5 Knight captures on e5
and now Knight to c3
now karana continues developing we have
Queen to e7 and rook a to d1 here we
have rook to e8
you can't really attack this Bishop by
moves like Knight to g4 we already
mentioned or
or even Knight to c4 the bishop always
can go to d4 and this will be a very
nice square for the bishop if you try
something like c5 to take away the d4
square from the this Bishop then Knight
to a4 and you really lost control of the
d5 square Knights the d5 is coming this
will be a beautiful position for white
if you try to stop it then white will
simply capture it say thank you for the
bishop prepare and you will not have
three point on it
pawn islands with black a nice long turn
advantage for white so after locate the
d1 rook to e8 was played and the now
comes Knight to f4 as the knight is no
longer useful on h3 c6 Anand has to keep
keep an eye on this d5 square and here
we have Bishop to d4 a very nice idea we
have g5 attacking this night and now
nice to d3 Knight captures on d3 by
anand rook captures on d3 and dena comes
at Bishop to e5 offering a trade of dark
square bishop and it seems like Ananda
successfully parried any threats that
were created with this fancy Bishop to
e3 variation he just has to exchange a
couple of more pieces this light square
bishop dark a light square bishop is
coming into into the game rook is coming
to d8 and always well for black and this
is in fact true black is perfectly fine
here here karana spent 18 minutes on his
next move and he really had to calculate
a whole lot of things he plays a Queen
to d2 a very useful move you don't want
your Queen on the same diagonal as this
Bishop as you know this Bishop is coming
to f5 and also at some point you're
guarding the f4 square at some point you
will push efore and f4 so here we have
Bishop to f5 by Anand and okay you
definitely do want to develop this
Bishop if you play something like butter
to capture some d4 and go for exchanges
immediately then look after Sundy for
still have to develop the bishop for
example the five now E 4 is coming
Bishop to g6 and rook to d1
you will have this beautiful rook Queen
rook battery on the D file and
with white controlling the only open
file on the board this is complete
control
white would have a huge advantage in
this game a very very little control for
black here
so instead after Queen to d2 Anand first
develops vegetable we have Bishop to a5
attacking the rook
efore the best move Bishop to g6 now the
bishop has been developed and joins the
defense of the King and here karana
again spends 15 minutes on his next move
and he plays f4 and this is in fact as
it would seem at the critical moment in
the game and interestingly Anand didn't
spend all that much time on this move he
spent half the time karana spent
preparing it
he ran and played G captures on f4 and
this is in fact not the greatest idea
better was a bunch of captures on d4 and
now after rook captures on d4 rook a to
d8 and now either you will exchange
rooks or you will push a 5 as ePHI se4
is definitely a target but now Queen to
c5 simply attacking the pin piece and
here black is black is blacks position
is fine located d1 defending and now
after Knight to h5 black will simply
exchange here and everything is war for
black but instead after f/4g captures on
f4 was played by Anand and it seems he
missed Coronas idea karana plays Bishop
captures on e5 and now things are a bit
different when the exchange happens on
e5 instead of on d4 Queen captures on e5
we have G captures on f4 attacking the
Queen and now comes Queen to c5 with
check King to h1 and now what do you do
here you don't want to allow ePHI where
f5 if something like this happens even
though the material on the board is
equal your position is just worse on the
nose that there's a really no point in
playing this so you do have to play
something the problem is if you play
Bishop captures on e4 this doesn't work
because Knight captures and after Knight
captures Bishop captures rook captures
then you have this Queen to g2 check
checking the King and picking up the
rook for example King moves and now
Queen captures on e4
white would be a baroque
completely winning on the other hand if
you don't capture it and play something
like ink 2h8 still doesn't really matter
f5 is coming and after the bishop moves
Queen captures on h6 black black is
terrible here white will easily win this
game so after King 2h one island has to
capture it he plays Knight captures on
e4 and now we have Knight captures on e4
and here again Bishop captures on e4 is
impossible again you have the same idea
but rope captures rook captures Queen g2
check King moves and grabbing the rook
so on ins idea is different instead of
Bishop captures he plays rook captures
on e4 and okay now white definitely
can't capture if you captured in black
will capture with check pick up the rook
and the black would be better here since
black is now up upon but karana has
something prepared for this
after this rook captures on e4 move
first he plays rook to g3 simply pinning
the bishop here and now your black is in
huge trouble here what can you do here
if you simply move the King for example
King to h7 white will not capture the
rook and allow Bishop captures red or
white to simply capture on g6 and after
I've captures only then recapture on e4
white is up a full piece completely
winning game for white so instead after
this rook to g3 Anand has to deal with
two threats one is Bishop captures rook
as the bishop on g6 is pinned and the
other one if you move the rook is
definitely f5 as sorry f5 pinning this
bishop so you don't have to pair those
two threats under desert with rook to d4
simply attacking the Queen and now the
rock moved out of danger next move Anand
is hoping to prevent DF 5 move so
knowing these two things
pause the video here and try to find it
the only winning move for white in this
position and give yourself a minute or
two it's not it's not perhaps the
easiest idea to find and you have to
look a bit some three to four moves
ahead
so as usual I'll give you a couple of
seconds and just aside for those of you
who are able to do it congratulations
you have just a beaten former world
champion and
current rapid world champion which
monitor and and for those of you just
want to enjoy the show
the move is Queen to III the idea Queen
- III is the only winning move is
because well it's better to explain it
by playing a move that isn't winning for
example Queenie one if you play Queen T
we want simply moving the Queen outta
the attack then black will block the f1
simply with Queen to f5 and now there's
no way to dislodge the Queen Bishop to
h3 will be met with coming to d5 check
you move the bishop back Queen back to
f5 black you know get got out of the
attack and now it's everything is fine
from black on the other hand after Queen
to e3 which Caruana played and it is in
fact after this moved that Vishwanathan
Anand resigned to the game he resigned
because now there really isn't anything
you can do Queen to f5 no longer works
here because your rook is under attacked
and there's a really nothing to play
here for example if you move the King
King to h7 you want to unpin the bishop
still you get f5 and now there's really
nothing to do here the problem is for
example if you move the bishop and this
is the idea why you had to find that
Queen to e3 was so powerful because the
h3 pawn is still under it at the HS
exponents to under attack now bushell
286 brush up to h5 loses to look to h3
now you can't do anything with the
bishop the bishop is lost if you move it
you get clean h6 check King moves and
Queen - h8 checkmate on the other hand
after f5 if you just capture the pawn
which is you know your absolute
privilege to do so as simply rook
captures on f5 Queen captures Queen
captures and before again you are up a
whole piece winning the game easily so
yeah Anand calculated everything
precisely after Queen to e3 he resigned
the game and a wonderful victory for
Fabiano Caruana and a very important
victory at that because it was due to
this game that the United States have
defeated India in round 4 of the of the
Olympiad as all of the other games were
drawn only the game on board one had a
decisive result so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it
I'm gonna check up on a couple of more
games from the Olympian as I've seen
there have been quite a lot of upsets so
we're gonna talk about the results of
the Olympiad so far and also I've mean
I've been meaning to address one thing a
lot of you have been asking me
we have via social media or you know in
the comment section or something that
you've played a game and that your
opponent is cheating because he castles
through check what do I mean by this
well let's just create any position
doesn't really matter for example let's
just place I'm sorry it was just play
something meaningless I'm just trying to
create a position where such a thing was
possible let's see let's say white
blonde or a bishop here let's say this
is a game between two complete beginners
because most likely it's the beginners
who don't know the rules of chess and
okay it's not really not really the best
option but let's say okay let's say hmm
yeah I thought totally messed up let's
just clear the board a bit here let's
say captures captures captures okay
white blunders a piece doesn't really
matter let's say this is here captures
captures the knight goes here let's say
let's say white pushes h4 for some
reason black develops the bishop Bishop
to e7 let's see g4 is played like the
black castles and okay let's say black
cast okay let's say c3 and black plays
Bishop to d5 attacks the rook and this
is the problem now some people think
that if the bishop is controlling any of
these squares any of these four squares
that now castling is impossible but that
is in fact not the case you you can
always castle unless any of the pieces
is cutting off the squares that King
will use well castling so well when
castling happens the King comes to g1 so
as you see the King only used f1 and g1
to Castle so this Bishop is only
controlling the h1 square if this bishop
was
for somehow controlling either the g1 or
the f1 squared then you could not Castle
for example if instead on d5 this Bishop
was still here now white definitely
can't castle because the bishop is
controlling the f1 square or if this
instead of this castling let's say
Bishop to c5 was play the white goes
Knight b3 and okay let's say captures
captures white will still not be able to
castle because the dark square bishop is
now controlling the g1 square so if you
cut off the King's weight to the hunter
to the castling and then you cannot
castle but just because for example the
rook is under attack here as you can see
here like we've already said okay I lost
it now in so many okay here then it
doesn't really matter you can still
castle here because the king is not even
touching h1 the rook who will simply
jump over the king and the castling is
allowed here
so okay it's a weird way to end in the
video but a lot a lot of you have been
asking me this so I decided if you're
watching this video I do hope and now
you will be able to properly castle and
you will not accuse your opponent of
cheating when you see this happen so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you're enjoying this
well for now short coverage of the
Olympic but I will improve it with some
more games I would like to thank Scott
Hamilton Andruw Jones Dan Hanson
Adrianne's Arcola and Daniel search well
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I'll see you soon hopefully with
some more interesting videos and do
check up on all the links in the
description below to the official batumi
chess olympiad
social media thank you all and I'll see
you soon